gleichzeitig gibt es eine nachricht
heute früh deutschland bestellt f-35
tarnkappenjets und das ist so ziemlich
das beste und teuerste es hier sehen wir
sie mal was so auf dem markt gibt us
tarnkappen jet vom typ f-35 bis zu 35
stück davon soll die deutsche luftwaffe
jetzt bekommen und damit dann die alten
tornados ersetzen und das macht eine rot
grün gelbe regierung ja schon
spektakulär grüne außenministerin zum
beispiel
sozialdemokratische relativ linke
verteidigungsministerin auch christine
lambrecht und die wollen jetzt diese
modernsten jets kaufen also was wollen
wir jetzt wissen von unserem bild
militärexperten maximilian kiewel was
ist das besondere an dieser entscheidung
für diese f-35 für diese tarnkappenjets
also diese entscheidung ist eine weitere
absolute 180 grad kehrtwende in der
deutschen sicherheits- und
verteidigungspolitik warum man muss sich
das mal vorstellen
2018 also vor gerade einmal vier jahren
er ist der damalige inspekteur der
luftwaffe also der höchste generale
deutsche luftwaffe dafür
rausgeflogen kann man sagen weil er
öffentlich erklärt hatte dass er für
seine truppe die f35 haben will das war
damals politisch nicht gewollt man hat
dann jahrelang auch das kann man so
sagen rumgeeiert zwischen lösungen
gesucht und jetzt also diese klare
entscheidung für die f35 für den
modernsten jet den es eben auf der welt
gibt unter den soldaten oder für die
soldaten sicherlich eine absolute
sensation was ich gehört habe in den
letzten monaten war aber dass die
entscheidung dahin geht dass eben die
spitze der luftwaffe der neuen
bundesregierung noch einmal probiert hat
zu erklärt warum das eben die lösung ist
die deutschland braucht und jetzt eben
durch die diesen angriffskrieg von
wladimir putin durch das was wir sehen
an der nato ostflanke ist man dann
offenbar bei der politik in der politik
dann doch zu der entscheid bekommen dass
dieser jet genau das ist was deutschland
was die bundeswehr was die luftwaffe
jetzt braucht ja da fragen wir uns
natürlich wofür brauchen verdi und was
können die f35 überhaupt max
die f35 die ist ein jet der sogenannten
fünften generation und das sicherlich
besonders da an der 35 ist dass sie eben
für gegnerische radarsysteme offenbar
nicht zu erkennen ist ich habe dir 35 32
erlebt denn die israelis sie fliegen
diese r35 auch und eigentlich sozusagen
mehr als alle anderen aktionen deutlich
sie wirklich im kampf einsatz und die
israelis diesen stolz darauf was sie
sagen die f35 die ist bei uns so gut wie
in jedem land überhaupt in dem nahen
osten einsatz also anders gesagt wir
können mit diesem flugzeug dahin fliegen
wo wir wollen weil wir eben nicht
erkannt werden die f 35 hat für die
israelis schon geburt und zerstört für
die israelis schon andere luft ziele
ausgeschaltet und hat dort sozusagen ja
in realen situationen bewiesen wo für
sie da ist und was sie kann in
deutschland kommt zumindest theoretisch
sicherlich noch eine weitere aufgabe
hinzu denn es gibt einen vertrag ein
abkommen unter nato staaten zwischen
deutschland zwischen den usa die im
absoluten ernstfall garantiert dass
deutschland und deutsche jazz
amerikanische atombomben aufnehmen und
in ihr ziel bringen würden also abwerfen
wird und dafür braucht es natürlich
kampfjets kampfbomber die dafür
zertifiziert sind die diese atombomben
aufnehmen könnten die auf deutschem
boden gelagert aber eben in
amerikanischen kasernen gelagert sind
und das ist eben eine aufgabe die wie
gesagt im schlimmsten ernstfall auf die
er 35 und auf die besatzung der f 35
dann auch zu kommen würde und so
militärexperte maximilian kiewel
verunglückt sei